welcome to exploring computing
today's video is big data
so i've referred to big data previously
in the last video
and the basic idea behind big data is we
can use
processing power to extract useful
information from massive amounts of data
and as the cost of storing information
is decreasing
we're able to collect more and more data
as our processing power is increasing
we're able to more easily process it
and it turns out that new techniques in
artificial intelligence and specifically
machine learning
are giving us new ways to process large
amounts of data
and so big data is referring to this
ability
to process the large amounts of data
that we didn't have previously
those that study big data sometimes
refer to the three v's of big data
the first v is the volume of information
how much information do we have
the second v is velocity how quickly is
that data arriving
if the data is not arriving that quickly
we can often
process it in real time as it's
streaming in
however if there's too much information
for us to handle
we're going to need large storage
facilities in order to store that
information and then
batch process the information at some
later point in time
the third v is variety how many
different types of data
are we dealing with um in general we can
divide the data into two types
structured data
which is data that is easy for the
computer to process so something like a
table of information like say
a past list of passenger manifests
that's super easy for the computer to
deal with it's already in a format that
the computer understands
in contrast unstructured data is much
harder for the computer to
process and this might be something like
a video so
suppose we have a video of people
arriving and
departing from a passenger terminal that
obviously is going to take a lot of work
on our first to process it and get some
useful information
out of it some researchers have added a
fourth fee
to the previous three v's and that is
the veracity of the data and i think
unfortunately our current environment
this makes a lot of sense
so how accurate is the information we're
working with
and how sure we have the data sources so
i think particularly with things like
deep fakes
and uh poor actors like russian bot
accounts say on twitter
it becomes increasingly important for us
to think about where our data sources
are
and what those data sources can tell us
now
you know obviously if you've got
something like
a russian bot account actually studying
the russian bot accounts themselves with
big data techniques can
also give you some information but you
do need to
you know carefully think about what your
sources of data are
and what they mean
uh one thing that big data can be used
for is removing anonymity on
data that is thought to be anonymous so
in one example
netflix released a set of data with the
names removed and
allowed different data researchers to
work with that data and
learn from it and it turns out that
a group from the university of texas
austin
was able to remove the anonymity of the
data
what they did was they compared the data
that netflix had provided
uh with things like what different
um people watching netflix had watched
and uh back then we used to be able to
give movies number of stars instead of
just thumbs up and thumbs down on
netflix
and what they did was they compared the
ratings provided in the anonymous data
with
ratings provided at imdb by various
users
and even if somebody only had a
few ratings out at imdb they were able
to match up imdb accounts with netflix
accounts
and on that basis they were able to
figure out what
different users at an imdb had actually
watched
netflix even though the imdb
users had not intended to release their
viewing habits out on netflix
one famous use of big data is the target
store's pregnancy detection
story so this is coming from an article
in the new york times
and i've included a link to this article
in your class notes
so the background on the story is
typically uh
and this this uh background is from some
research at ucla
typically customers form habits and shop
at the same stores for mundane items so
if you're buying
you know we all have to buy soap
toothpaste trash bags
and other items on a fairly regular
basis and
typically we're just going to buy them
at the exact same stores all the time
over and over and over again
but those buying habits can change
during major life events such as
when we get married or when we buy a new
house or something like that and it
turns out one of the big
event is of course having children so
when somebody is having a child
that's a big opportunity for stores to
step in and try and change buying habits
of
of different people and in addition
another nice thing about pregnancy from
the starts point of view
is new unexpected parents can be
expected to buy lots of stuff i
can also point out that the same thing
is true of people buying a house
you buy a new house and suddenly your
expenses go up for a while because
you realize you've got all the stuff
that you need for the house
that you never thought of before now
as far as pregnancy goes um and
childbirth goes there are
official public birth records but
everybody has access to them
and so if you wait for the public birth
records to come out
you're going to be bombarding these
parents with advertisements at the exact
same time as everybody else is going to
bombard them with information and so
target wanted a way to get a jump up on
their competitors
and discover when people were pregnant
before their competitors were able to
from the poke birth records
now in order to do this target actually
had a
bunch of key data sets that really
helped them out the first thing is
they had information on their the
purchasing habits on
some of their customers if you have a
discount card for a different store
those discount cards are used to track
your information
so the bargain is you're going to get a
discount on purchases but in return
the store is going to be able to
identify your particular purchase
patterns in addition they have
other information for example they may
have your age
your marital status the number of kids
you have and in the case of target they
knew how
far you lived from at the closest target
store and had an estimate of salary
so that was one data set target had and
then the second data set that target had
was
people who had registered for the target
baby shower registry so they had one set
of information on the buying habits and
they were able to identify specifically
when some of those people were pregnant
and have some idea on the timing there
and so what they did was they
took all the information and used big
data techniques they were able to
discover that pregnant women
purchased large quantities of unsent
lotions at the beginning of the second
trimester
they purchased supplements of calcium
magnesium and zinc
for the first 20 weeks and they
purchased scent-free soap and extra
large bags
of cotton balls in total target was able
to identify
25 different items that acted as
pregnancy indicators
they also learned some lessons about
advertising
basically they learned that if you send
people advertisements filled with
baby items they find that kind of creepy
and so
they decided they were better off mixing
uh mixing advertisements
so quoting from the article they were
basically mixing in all these ads for
things that we knew pregnant women would
never buy so that the baby ads looked
random
we'd put an ad for a lawn mower next to
diapers as long as the pregnant woman
thinks she hasn't been spied on she'll
use the coupons
there's another amusing anecdote from
the story
um a man walked into target
outside of minneapolis and demanded to
see the manager he was clutching coupons
that had been sent to his daughter and
he was angry according to an employee
who participated in the conversation
my daughter got this in the mail he said
she's still in high school and you're
sending her
coupons for baby clothes and cribs are
you trying to encourage her to get
pregnant
the manager didn't have any idea what
the man was talking about
he looked at the mailer and sure enough
it was addressed to the man's daughter
and contained
advertisements for maternity clothing
nursery furniture and pictures of
smiling infants
the manager apologized and then called a
few days later to apologize again
on the phone though the father was
somewhat abashed
i had to talk with my daughter he said
it turns out there have been some
activities in my house
i haven't been completely aware of she's
due in august
i owe you an apology all right so
another fine story about what computing
can do
i'll talk to you all again soon